let's begin with the high stakes
political standoff over choosing a new
Speaker of the House lawmakers adjourned
yesterday after Republicans refused to
unite behind California Congressman
Kevin McCarthy in three consecutive
votes McCarthy failed to get the support
he needs to become speaker the last time
it took more than one round of voting
that was 100 years ago lawmakers will
vote again today Scott McFarland is on
Capitol Hill following all the drama
Scott good morning
Vlad good morning until they choose a
speaker there is no sitting U.S House of
Representatives the members elect
haven't taken the oath of office the
positions second in line to the
presidency behind the vice president is
vacant and for Kevin McCarthy and the
opposition in his own party there is no
clear path forward today
a speaker has not been elected a
dramatic standoff that paralyzed the
first day of the newly elected U.S House
of Representatives resumes today with
the potential for more chaos this is not
personal
it's not
this is about the future of the country
a group of conservative House
Republicans defied GOP leader Kevin
McCarthy denying him the votes needed to
be speaker in three successive votes
with their numbers only increasing from
19 to 20. McCarthy can only afford to
lose four of his colleagues I like Kevin
but I think he thought the majority was
going to be a lot bigger and he didn't
need us that's the problem McCarthy said
late Tuesday he won't drop out of the
race for speaker and is willing to make
further concessions to win over
skeptical hardliners
this is a healthy debate it might not
happen on the day we want it but it's
going to happen I Rise to nominate Kevin
McCarthy for Speaker of the House
one named the faction of Republicans who
defied McCarthy offered as an
alternative is Ohio Republican Jim
Jordan a close Ally of Donald Trump's
the congressman Jordan says he supports
McCarthy and isn't seeking the job and I
think Kevin McCarthy is the right guy to
lead us I really do or I wouldn't be
standing up here given this speech The
Honorable Hakeem Jeffries of the state
of New York has received 212. Democrats
remain unified throughout the first day
of ballots unanimously voting for their
new leader Hakeem Jeffries of New York
the Republican dysfunction is what it is
chaos crisis and confusion along with
craziness but what if McCarthy's key
allies told CBS News if the Republican
defectors don't relent McCarthy might
need to lure Democratic votes by
offering perks like added seats on
prized house committees these folks
think that we're that they have us over
a barrel that we have nowhere else to
turn no
for now the elected have not taken the
oath of office and that includes
embattled congressman-elect George
Santos of New York who's accused of
widespread lies he did not answer
reporter questions including mine
yesterday about his background adding to
his troubles Brazilian authorities say
they're going to renew charges tied to a
2008 fraud case against Santos who sat
Vlad in the back row during votes
yesterday
all right Scott so for the American
people to understand why this is so
important to use the word paralyze if
there is no speaker of the house and
this drags out what does that mean for
our government governing can't happen
they can't legislate and fix problems
throughout America and they'll find it
difficult these members elect to rectify
problems in communities related to
Veterans Benefits somebody's social
security check that's missing a missing
passport or passport issue what's more
they can't form committees and as
Republicans have promised investigate
the Biden Administration Vlad they are
very much politically and functionally
paralyzed
all right Scott it all kicks off at noon
we know you'll be there thank you very
much